Speaker 1: Camilla, the shameless or shallow?
I'm not exactly sure. The pronunciation is a
congressional reporter at The Washington Post.
She did a great thing where she spoke to a bunch
of residents in George Santos's district who voted
for him. And here is what some of them had to say
about whether they want Santos to go. Do you feel.
Speaker 5: Like regret for voting for him? Yes,
of course. Why? Because he's dishonest
and he has no experience.
Speaker 1: I am outraged by it.
Speaker 6: And the idea that he should, you
know, be able to remain in office is ludicrous.
Speaker 5: When you voted for him, what was your
initial like? Why you plan to vote for him? Oh,
he seemed to be, you know, somebody who just
gave a damn about his neighborhood. I think
they cared about people in general. So I really
was pretty. I just watched the Queen on. Why
do people like to be in office now?
Speaker 1: So Santos insists that none of
the people that voted for him want him to resign,
but it seems that they do. And I continue to be
disturbed by the ease with which none of this
stuff surfaced before the election. And, you know,
again, I'm not necessarily pointing fingers,
but opposition research didn't turn it up and
journalistic work didn't turn it up. It seems
like if you're going to get a job at a cell phone
store, you are vetted more thoroughly ultimately
than than how George Santos was vetted. Now,
this news spoke to high schoolers from
his district who will be able to vote in
the next election. Here's what they had to say.
Speaker 6: I am from Port Washington, New York.
Schreiber High School in Long Island's Nassau
County is in the heart of Representative George
Santos's third Congressional District.
Speaker 2: I mean, I think he's an
embarrassment and a pathological liar.
Speaker 6: True, He sat down with a group
of AP US history students at Schreiber High.
They are 16 and 17, which means they will all be
old enough to vote in 2024. How many of you would
register as an independent if you register today?
Not many of you would register as a Democrat.
Speaker 1: All but two.
Speaker 6: How many of you
would register as a Republican?
Speaker 1: Two of them.
Speaker 6: Their history
teacher estimates Republican leaning students
are outnumbered by Democratic leaning students
by an almost 2 to 1 margin at the school.
Speaker 7: But I haven't found one kid
who is sympathetic to George Santos. They
know the importance of the numbers in the
House of Representatives. And although Santos
represents them for issues that they agree on,
they don't have sympathy toward the men.
Speaker 6: 16 year old Tahj Parikh is
one of the future Democrats.
Speaker 4: I think it's it's
a very scary situation for us having someone who
is so clearly lied and so clearly fabricated his
entire resume representing all of us.
Speaker 6: 16 year old Nathan Jackman
is one of the future Republicans.
Speaker 8: I like how the national
GOP came out against him, but obviously Kevin
McCarthy should come out against him. True.
And they should have a vote on the House
floor in order to expel them from Congress.
Speaker 1: Put every single member of Congress
on the record. I want the liar to stay or I want
the liar to go. We this guy's got to go. And I
every day that goes by that he remains in office,
I worry that he is going to be able to stay.
If you want to check out these clips I've
played will have them all on our Instagram,
which you can find by searching Instagram for
David Pakman show. We're going to take a quick
break. What a program we have for you today.